okay this is building useful project
details with Python my name is Johan
Harlan I work as a software engineer at
Cisco in Norway I work on some
application level programming but also
do more underlying platform work version
control build systems developer tools
all the stuff that makes our main
application run successfully on our
software platform for this talk I'm
going to assume that you have some basic
familiarity with UNIX shell scripting
bash is the typical language used but
they're all very similar and I'm also
going to assume that you have some
familiarity with Python 3 if your
experience is mostly in Python 2 that
also works some of these things are not
available in Python 2 you can usually
find alternatives there but python 3 is
where the future of python lies anyway
so that's what I'm going to concentrate
on so I'm gonna start with some
motivation of this talk what shell
scripts are we talking about what are
shell scripts good for why is Python all
almost always better then I'm going to
go through the conversion from a shell
script to Python some tips and
techniques you could use how you
organize your code how to write good
command-line interfaces in Python how to
run other programs from Python because
that's usually what you do from a shell
script how to manipulate the file system
from Python another common shell
scripting also I'm going to talk a
little bit about writing unit tests in
Python and that's typically not
something unit testing something you do
in shell scripts but that's one of the
big advantages with moving to Python you
can start doing this so I have a
slightly controversial take on error
handling that I'll talk about and then
I'm gonna move into a case study of a
real world shell script that I rewrote
into Python and at Cisco and how I first
of all how I needed to do that because I
need to add features that would have
been impossible in shell but just
walking through the process and then
some summary and some room for questions
at the end hopefully so
what kind of scripts are we talking
about here I sort of informally termed
this the glue that holds your project
together if you go into your codebase
you'll almost always find bunch of shell
scripts lying around everywhere there
might be developer tools so like you
have some complex command that is part
of your workflow and instead of
remembering the whole command you
basically just put that into a shell
script and you just run the shell script
instead and so this could be for like
running profiling or just helping you
with deploying your changes through the
build process onto your embedded product
or whatever you're making shell scripts
are often used at Build time as well if
you have a very simple project maybe
your whole build system is a shell
script but generally you have a more
complex build system and if you say auto
generate code or you need some kind of
helper for some part of your build
system that might be implemented in the
shell scripts people often use shell
scripts for packaging deployment and
release publishing your assets to some
server where they're well built your
customer signing release images if
you're doing that kind of things and at
the end in production and your customer
like if you're shipping a product that
product itself might have shell scripts
running on it so your shell scripts
basically running in at your customer
site as well so shell scripts like we
use them all the time so they must be
good for something well they are real
good for short and simple stuff if your
logic is straightforward and you don't
have any date structures yes shell
scripts is a really good solution it
helps you to take say a complex command
or a few commands and wrap them into a
nice little wrapper and you don't have
to remember all this stuff inside
but once shell script starts growing if
you add more and more logic to them if
you need some data structures in there
if you need some configurability say
from the command line and if you start
refactoring things into functions to
make them reusable yeah it supports some
of that but it quickly becomes
horrible mess basically if you open the
shell script and it's longer than a
screen full of text it takes quite a bit
of motivation to actually get into it
and understand what it does because it
has quite a esoteric syntax something
sometimes and also as your shell scripts
grow you'll run into safety problems
pretty soon you have to be very
disciplined as a shell script programmer
to write this a safe shell script code
I'll look at some some more examples
here soon so why is Python any better so
I'm just going to do a quick comparison
between shell and Python
so for shell you have a fairly easy
syntax it's very similar to what you
know from the command line works so if
you if you used to working on the
command line those skills are
transferable into a shell script because
it's basically just commands one command
after another one so it's easy to become
product productive but the complexity
like once once you write more and more
complex shell scripts that basically
become write only scripts it's really
really hard to read them you write them
once and then if you have to make
changes that's how that's hard but shell
has one thing going for it it's it's
trivial to run all the programs for
shell and that's basically how shell
scripts are the whole reason for shell
scripts because shell itself is a very
very minimal language you don't have
much in in terms of utilities available
in the language itself it's all about
running your other system utilities to
get stuff done it's fairly or reasonably
easy to learn shell because you can
search online and you can find lots of
resources and examples but a lot of the
shell scripts you find online are not
always of any good quality and here is
my favorite sort of safety feature there
are more safety problems in shell but
this is the most common one so we have
this file name variable
and we set it to this file name and then
we try to touch that file name well what
you'll actually end up here is you're
going to touch three files you're going
to touch one file called my another file
called favorite and a third file called
quotations dot txt because this is what
shell does shell don't do types of
variables and and string handling very
well especially in
once you move out of the scope of eight
character long filenames without spaces
and yeah like there are lots of pitfalls
in shell scripts on the other hand
Python has a very simple and beginner
friendly syntax the the learning curve
for Python is is fairly shallow in that
you can get productive quickly with a
very small subset of language
lots of people consider PI's in one of
the most readable languages it's not as
trivial to run other programs from
Python as it is from shell but it's
fairly easy and I'm gonna walk through
some of those ways
it definitely has fewer pitfalls than
shell you don't have to worry about this
our strings are treated in this way and
you have to keep that in mind when you
write these scripts there's lots of
literature and resources online to learn
Python and when you find a Python
example like Patton has a fairly good
consistent style to it and the examples
you find online are usually in my
opinion at least or in my experience
there are a better quality than the
example shell scripts you find online
data structures and types so in shell
everything is a string Y space as I said
in values of cost problems and you must
be very careful when dealing with
variables and their values in shell
there is some support for integer
arithmetic and some support for IRAs
especially if you move into the more
advanced shell scripting languages like
bash but if you want to stay to a common
subset there are very limited things you
can do and I found this quote from the
advanced bash scripting guide which i
think is gold
unlike many and especially at a
conference like this where there is lots
of C++ and also high-level talks about
advanced types and how to basically
build good type systems this is this is
so so different unlike many other
programming languages bash does not
segregate its variables by tight
essentially bash variables are character
strings but depending on context bash
permits arithmetic operations and
comparisons on variables the determining
factor is whether the value of a
variable contains only digits so that's
a fairly fresh take on the whole concept
of types when you come from something
like C++ for example Python on the other
hand a
very dynamic dynamically typed in that
variable doesn't you don't specify the
type of variable and it has to stay that
way
you do have type limitations in in
modern Python but I'm not going to cover
that here it's dynamically typed but
it's also strongly typed when python has
determined the type of variable python
is fairly strict about handling that
type it's not like integers to suddenly
turn into strings or strings turn into
integers or you can concatenate a
floating-point value with a string like
you can in JavaScript for example and I
find this a fairly good balance in
Python it allows you to do a lot of
things very easily but still Python will
prevent you from doing a lot of easy
mistakes that you can do when you have a
weakly typed language you have a fair
amount of built-in types you have the
usual numerix in floating complex you
have sequences you have lists and tuples
and ranges you have text and binary data
sets and dict which is the mapping type
dictionary and then you have other types
as well basically in in Python
everything is an object so even your
modules that you've write in Python your
closest close instances functions
methods yeah exceptions everything is an
object and it's very dynamic you can
introspect through the language and look
up say I imported this module can I
III can now loop through the various
functions I were available for from that
module for example modularity so when
you write the shell you can structure
your shell scripts with functions the
scoping behavior of functions decels
shell scripts are not always obvious
there are some weird rules where
variables are global by default for
example so if you run a function and
there it modifies variable internally
that might actually modify some global
variable and you might not expect that
depending on how much experience you
have with shell scripts if you're
talking about modularity between files
basically putting your code into
different shell scripts and and
accessing it
you can exit in two ways you can either
from one shell script directly invoke
another shell script as a basically as a
separate process or you can use the
source statement or in some some
dialects basically simply a dot so when
you just call a shell script you
basically run it as a separate process
but when you use the source you can
think of that as a hash included
basically the source of that shell
script is run within the context of your
shell script so if that's a super
variable you can now access that
variable from your script but if you
write a script to be sourced by another
script well a script cannot easily
figure out whether it has been sourced
by a different script or whether it was
just called from the command line or
call from somewhere else so typically
when you write the script you either
write it as a list of instructions to be
performed and there might be some
functions for refactoring your
functionality out of there or you write
it simply as a bag of functions that if
you run just run it it does nothing
except declare those functions and maybe
some variables and it's basically
intended just for being sourced by all
the shell scripts which which then
contain your your main functionality in
Python so within a Python file you can
structure code into functions but you
also have classes and you have proper
data structures so this allows you to
basically factor your code in into a
form that is most suitable for what
you're trying to express between files
you can access Python files in in in two
ways I basically put import first here
because that's what you're going to do
the most often so import you could think
of that as like source in in shell in
that your Python program gets direct
access to a different Python file but it
has proper namespaces so if like if I
source a shell script here from some
other shell script and it's declares a
variable foo that variable foo is now
directly in my namespace
there is no concept of separate
namespaces but in Python if I import the
module then
the stuff in that module is accessible
to me by default via that modules name
dot something so that's sort of
separated into its own namespace it
doesn't pollute my namespace I can also
call a another Python script by a
subprocess to basically call it as a
regular process that's typically not
what you do between Python programs
though and one one small detail I'm
going to cover later here is if you have
a main guard and I'm going to show you
what that is that allows for a Python
script to detect whether it's run
directly or whether it was imported from
some other module and this allows a
Python file to be written both as the
shells as a script that can be run from
the command line and as a module that
can be imported from other Python code
and this is quite a useful concept so
here's the shell script food of SH it
basically starts out by echoing this to
the screen this is always run and then
it declares a function that does another
echo so yeah if I just run food of Sh
it's gonna do that and it's going to
carry this function but it's not going
to run that function I'm not calling
this function so this this will not show
up if you just run food authorization
and then you have Bartle sh this one
sources foo and then it runs that
function so in both cases well when when
I run food this one is gonna be printed
but I wanna run bar this one is going to
be printed and then I call foo and I'm
gonna print this one so this statement
is always run and there's no way no easy
way in shell for food to basically
detect that oh I'm being sourced so I
don't want to do this or now I'm being
run so now I want to do my main logic
whereas in Python so this is pretty
similar code Python basically says okay
I want to print this always and then I
declare this function foo right does
prints as well and I'm gonna skip that
for now a bar in bar we import food and
then we call food or food
work this function so now when I run bar
this import statement is actually gonna
run this code and it's gonna do the
print so this is always run even when
when you run bar this is also printed
and then it declares a function it
doesn't run it yet and then when it gets
down here it it's gonna say if name
equals main which basically means is
through the main script in this Python
process and if it's not we're just going
to skip this so from when few is run on
its own this is printed and this is
printed but when you run bar we import
food this is printed this is skipped and
you can basically you have this facility
in Python for free to detect that oh I'm
being imported I don't need to run this
and then we do this call down here and
it's gonna do the call to food so more
shell versus Python comparison tools in
libraries as I said the shell script
language itself is very minimal you use
system binaries from UNIX or from
elsewhere on your system to do the heavy
lifting
yeah in python python is very different
here part that's a very very rich
standard library you can do most things
within the language without having to
call out to external processes lots more
third-party modules are available on
lines so if you want to get even more
functionality you can find that there
and you can use the sub process module
to call out to other binaries on your
system so you can still interact with
all the binaries just like you depend on
from shell scripts it's slightly more
fiddly from Python than from shell
though so converting a shell script to
Python some tips and techniques first
just how to organize your code as we saw
earlier here the Python script you can
have statements at the top level if
you're used to C and C++ you don't
really have this you can't like you need
to put something in you you need to put
your statements inside a function for
them to actually work you can just have
printf on the top level but you can in
Python and you do in shell so when
converting from shell to Python you can
simply start by transcribing your shell
script into Python once they've mint
after another you don't need to change
the structure at all everything is run
from top to bottom in the same way in
both languages and then you can start
refactoring your Python script or your
very shell like Python script with
functions and classes in the instructors
and you can sort of incremental e
improve the structure of your script and
you can add the main guard and this
makes it possible for your Python script
to be imported from another script
because before this so say you have a
shell scripts and it doesn't stuff like
say it removed some file all right move
some files around the file system if you
just rewrite that into Python the Python
script will do the same when you run it
it'll just move so fast around but if
you now import it that Python script
from a different Python script it would
still just go ahead and move those files
and you probably don't want to do that
when you import it from another script
because the reason to import it is to
access some reusable functionality
within your Python script and that's why
you add the main guard because now if
you protect the the main execution of
the script inside the main guard all the
other stuff becomes available without
your script going around and doing is
the stuff every time it is imported
after you've added the main guard
typically you'll add a main function as
well just to sort of organize the the
main execution record into a separate
function this is a common convention in
Python but it's also
another script can now import your
script and then run its main to
basically execute the script instead of
having to use some process run to
basically execute it in a separate
process and as you move along you can
split reusable functionality into
separate modules you can start
distributing your code over several
Python scripts to make sure that each
Grif does one thing does it well and has
yeah basically make sure that your code
is factored in a nice way and at this
point you can start adding unit tests to
verify the api's of those reusable
components so common line interfaces in
Python so a lot of shell scripts they
they're there for you or someone to run
from the command line so command line
interfaces is something you typically
write in shell I'm going to argue that
writing a command line interface in
Python it's a much better experience
than trying to do it properly in shell
first of all you're running on UNIX you
probably want to follow regular UNIX
conventions like if your script exists
with zero that means success if it X is
non zero that means failure nice thing
with Python is that if you just run some
states move through pythons and you
don't have an explicit exit it just
falls off the end of the script it's
gonna exit with 0 and if you throw an
exception inside Python and it's it
escapes and you get a trace back on the
on the command line it's also going to
make sure the exit code is is nonzero so
if just write a Python script you don't
worry about exit codes if it completes
this gonna exit 0 if it fails with some
exceptions it's gonna accept be nonzero
that's a nice convention or a nice
default at least one one typical thing
you do for a UNIX or in the UNIX
convention is to use C standard in and
sustain route for for default i/o so
standard in sign routes are these
conventions for getting your default
input and where you were to write your
default output
print in Python the focus is on the
route
so the defaults in place and are set up
to work with us if you use the logging
module in Python it's going to default
to printing your log messages on
standard error which is the UNIX
convention for logging errors and
warnings and typically when you write
your command-line interfaces how most
unix commands do this is that mandatory
command-line arguments are positional
arguments so say when you move a file
from A to B you don't have you the
command is MV a B so those are
processional arguments the first
argument the second argument you don't
use optional command-line arguments to
specify mandatory arguments and I'll
show you how basically doing this is in
Python is is fairly simple so the key
here is the arc parse module this is
part of the patent sign library and it's
what you want to use to write nice
command-line interfaces so here's a
fairly simple product program let's just
quickly go through what it does so we
have a string at the top declaring the
intention of the program and we
calculate the square of a given number
we have a helper function here called
calc it takes a number and exponent and
it returns the number raised to the
exponent this is just an example to show
ya all simple nothing nothing magic
going on here and then we have a main
function we have some command line
parsing here I'll go through that and
basically we have this main garden here
so if the name of this module is dunder
main so double underscore main or in
Python lingo dunder for double
underscore main if if if this script is
run from the command line basically then
we're going to call the main function so
at this point we're going to do the main
logic of the program if I wrote a
different Python script that imported
this one this would not hit we wouldn't
execute this this one would still be
available to my other script so now I
can import this script from a
different script and I can access the
calc functionality without having to run
the whole thing and without having to
parse command-line arguments or parse
command line arguments to get this one
to do the job I want and I want from it
but let's assume we're running it from
the command line we end up in main here
so here we set up a command line for
sure
so first the the argument parser takes
some description of your program I'm
basically assigning that from this dog
string up here and in Python you can
access that through looking at the
modules that you have loaded indexed by
this name to get this module and then
the dunder doc is this doc string up
here that's sort of a nice convention
like you can you can write a nice
comment at the top of your program and
that's also going to be part of your
usage message in in the command line
interface I'm going to show you that
then we had an argument we had an
argument called num this is a type int
which basically means that when Python
parses this command an argument is going
to run it through the int function which
will basically turn the string into an
integer so we take basically the number
to be squared we take that as our first
command-line argument then we add an
optional command-line argument - cube or
for short - 3 so you can basically have
aliases for 4 options here and this
you're going to use this command line
arguments to calculate the cube instead
of the square so basically we have an
option to to modify the the behavior of
the program this has an action of stores
true basically this means that cube is
going to be a boolean flag that's going
to go into default to false and if you
actually specify cube on the command
line it's going to sort through there
instead and then we're going to have
another optional argument file which is
basically where we want to write the
result and it's going to default to
standard route and I say this here the
fault equals is Thunder out and this
type argument here basically says that
when you write a filename and the
command line here
that file name is going to be parse or
passed to this thing which is basically
going to open
file for writing and give you the file
object so it's ready to be written to
but if you don't give anything you're
going to get cysts on the route which is
already a file object ready to be
written to so this is basically how I
declare the whole command-line interface
then we tell the parser to parse our
actual command-line arguments and you're
going to get those back in args and here
we can now call calc with a number from
the command line so this number becomes
args dot num and then if arcs does cube
so this is the boolean which defaults to
false but if you actually pass this
argument it's going to be true so
basically we're gonna call call calc
with the number and then we're going to
call it with 3 if that cube argument was
given else we're going to call it 4-2 so
we're going to end up calling Col care
with a number and the exponent which is
I had 3 or 2 and the result comes back
from calc and we're just going to print
that to the file the the arc stuff file
argument which by default will be our
standard output so yeah this is pretty
much exactly what I said I think yeah so
if you just run the script from the
command line
no arguments at all it's gonna complain
the following arguments are required num
so you didn't specify number so this
won't work but it's gonna print also a
small useless measure saying how to use
the script so basically you want to call
the script you can given - H - - cube or
a - file but you have to give a num now
if you run it with - H so this is sort
of a magic or an implicit help option
that the arc parts module will give you
and it'll now give you a nicely
formatted help for your command based on
the command line interface we just
defined so it's going to say let's
calculate the square of a given number
the positional arguments you need to
give is none and that's the number to be
squared and you have some optional
arguments here you can pass - help - H
or better Scheldt to get this message
you have the cube option with with help
string and the file option with the help
screen so now if we call my script with
5 we're going to
just get back the result 25 because
basically this is this was printed to
her stand her up but that was the
default option if I give it - 3 it's
going to cube instead so the Q both of 5
is 125 obviously and if I specify an
output file it's going to put that put
the result into the file called food and
then if I cut the file food I'm gonna
get the result so that was art bars now
let's look at how to run other programs
from your Python scripts um sir process
so basically you import the sir process
module you prepare a command line here
you want to prepare the command line
typically as list of strings Python
supports pausing the whole command line
as a single string as well but then it
needs to run it through the shell to get
shell expansion and everything sort of
properly decoded so everybody advices or
the advice is to basically pass a list
of strings this allows you to basically
handle command line arguments with
spaces in them properly and then you
basically call sub process dot run with
this list and that will run the sub
process and you can get the you can you
can use the return code attribute from
the call to get the exit code so that's
how you run a command and get a zexis
code if you want to run a command and
and raise an exception if it fails so if
it returns a nonzero exit code then you
basically just add check equals true to
the run call and you'll get an exception
if it fails so that's even easier than
getting the exit code and then doing an
if from the exit code sometimes you want
to run a process to actually catch its
output and put that into a string
variables so here's how you do that
typically you can pause check equals
true so that you can exception if the
program fails and capture output true
will basically now give you a result
object where you can extract the
standard out and the standard error from
that process so
there is this extra boilerplate of
sub-process run and and basically
organizing your command into an area of
strengths instead of a simple string but
otherwise it's not much harder to run an
external process in python than it is
from a shell script there are lots of
more complex cases for running external
commands you can set up pipes to the to
the external process and pipes the pipe
to standard output or get a pipe from
standard output and pipe from that
process to a different process and stuff
like that
all that is documented in the main
Python documentation and this is one of
the nice room Y jewels to read the
documentation for it's it's fairly
straightforward manipulating the
filesystem from Python this is another
thing that shell scripts often do and
you move some fast round you create some
directories you do something with the
file system from from a shell script so
how do you do the same for Python well
in Python 3 well yeah around around when
Python 3 showed up you also got the path
limb what you can get there's this one
Python too but it requires a separate
download but yeah the pathway module
allows you a nice interface for
manipulating paths basically so you can
create move remove files in directories
you can look for specific types of files
around the filesystem it has a nice
handling of relative versus absolute
paths in in large part it replaces or
supersedes always dot path functions and
other OS parts of Python if you're used
to those and it also supersedes F and
match for doing path pattern matching
like story dot txt
kind of matching and also glob which
actually goes onto the file system and
and and gets files that match a certain
pattern proper documentation is there
I'm just gonna do a very simple example
here OS and OS path are still in Python
and there are stuff there that is not in
path Lib so you'll still might need to
do these
there's also SH util which contains more
higher-level shell functionality but
here's a simple
live example so it starts by from path
lab import as the there there's some
other stuff in path flip but typically
the path is the clothes you want and
then we can say my directory equals path
dot CWD current working directory so
that's where your script is the current
directory for your script / so basically
path live has overloaded the slash
operator or the mission operator to
basically do path concatenation so here
we're basically getting the my dear
directory relative to the current
directory and then we create that recrea
and if it already exists well that's
fine we're just going to keep going if
you don't pass the exists okay equals
true then m'kay dear we'll raise an
exception if the directory exists and
then we're going to create a full path
which is the food or txt file inside
that my directory this just creates the
path object it doesn't actually create a
file and then if you don't exist so if
that file exists we're gonna rename it
to food dot
backup food with suffix backup basically
takes the lost suffix of the filename
and replaces it with the one you gave it
there and then with food or open wsf so
basically we're going to open the Foo
file in writable mode we're now going to
iterate through my directory so
basically get all the files or all the
paths within my directory and then we're
going to print that path relative to my
directory into that file so I'm
basically just taking a directory
listing of my deer and printing it into
that food txt file and then finally I'm
going to look up all the storage backup
files inside my directory and I'm gonna
unlink them so I'm not quite sure what
this program is meant to be doing but
it's a fairly nice example of what you
can do with path they pretty much all
we're doing here are methods on path
objects so a little bit about writing
unit tests in Python this yeah this is
not the talk on test frameworks or unit
testing in general but and typically
when your scripts grow you'll typically
put your assistance
separate files but I'm gonna just going
to show you some small tests that you
put it in the same file just to get
started unit testing you have lots of
different test frameworks available the
most used is probably unit test but a
lot of people don't like it pi test is
probably a better one and it's gaining
popularity fast but it's not in the
central library and there's doc test
which is very nifty and I'm I'm gonna
actually show you doctors first so
remember this drift this is the squaring
the numbers everything so I'm now going
to basically add some unit tests to the
script with each of the three methods so
four doc tests so if you just wanted to
add hoc test this script you can just
start the Python interpreter so
basically start the Python rifle you can
import my script and you can run my
script calc 3 2 basically you move the
square and number 3 and we get the
answer 9 so that's how you can sort of
interrogate your script from the command
line
now let's formalize that just a tiny bit
so in calc we add this doc string which
basically documents how documents the
module and typically in the doc string
you add a small message saying how to
use this or what it does but then let's
just copy some stuff from the Python
repple into the doc string so we're just
going to pretend there's a Python Python
doc string here we're just going to
tighten the three chevrons and then
we're going to type in some expression
and we're going to type in the result we
expect from this so here we're basically
making a list with three calls to calc
we're gonna square 0 we're gonna square
one and we're gonna square 2 and we're
going to expect that this results in a
list that contains the numbers 0 1 4 and
then we're going to do the same with
cubing and we're gonna expect a list
containing the values 0 1 and 8 and
we're basically just adding some
documentation or or some yeah a string
into the calc function itself and that's
all the change we're gonna do iterate
now from the command line we can run
Python - M doc test and then pass it my
script of Pi
we're just gonna add a dash D to get
somewhere boy stuff it as well and this
is now actually going to look through
the doc string look up the things that
look like Python expression
from the repple is going to execute them
with this module loaded and expect those
results that we expected here and it's
basically gonna run run calc with those
arguments and make sure that we get that
answer so this is fairly magic actually
but but it's it's really nice to just
get started doing some testing you
basically right ah this is a couple of
use cases for this function and then you
just run Python MDOC test and it's
actually going to test those use cases
you can also run doc test from within
the script itself so in your main guard
you can just import doc test and then
doctors the test mod for test this
module and it's going to do the same
thing when you run the script from the
command line for unit test unit tests
this is a bit more clunky you basically
set up some classes test case classes
and they have some test methods that do
stuff so you can add this into the same
file with along with the rest of the
stuff you need to add an import unit
test at the top to get access to the
unit test test case closest but these
are just classes that are declared
nothing is going to be run automatically
from your script there it's just going
to be sort of dead code in your script
but you can run these tests from the
command line by Python - I'm unit tests
on your script and it's going to find
these six tests and run them you can
also run them run the tests from within
the script like if you did not have a
command line interface for this you
could instead have what when invoked
from the command line
you're basically called unit tests of
main is that my test is a similar story
except the PI test tests are often nicer
and smaller to write so here we just
declare a function called test
underscore calc and the magic here is in
the name starts with test that's what pi
is going to recognize we set up some
test vectors so basically we're going to
take zero and square it and we're going
to expect zero we're gonna take one and
square it and expect one to N squared
and expect four and the same for the
cube test cases and then for the number
and the exponent and our expected value
in in this list we're going to assert
that when we call calc with a number and
exponent we get what we expect so very
simple example based testing in six
lines of code you can run this from the
command line if you have PI test
installed
you basically just do run PI test on
your script and it's going to find the
test and run them and you can also
import type I test from your script and
run it like that so a slightly
controversial take on error handling in
Python scripts and now I'm specific to
Python scripts for system utility is
basically Python scripts that have
replaced shell scripts don't often when
you write shell scripts or system
utilities these are scripts that don't
necessarily receive the same care and
attention that your main code base does
it's not where you do come complete
error handling it's not where you care
about all the cases and often what you
end up doing instead is you try to run
some code you catch some exceptions and
you basically just print an error
message and exit and instead of doing
die it's often better to have the Python
exception just bubble up to the command
line so that you can actually get the
trace back in the on the command line
part of the reason why I advocate this
as well is that these Python scripts
built us as system utilities as glue
code in your project
they are the users of those scripts are
often other developers and it's often
much quicker to basically get at Python
trace back trace back and directly sort
of identify ok this is the part of the
code that's failing let's start lucky
that then actually get an error message
and then trying to parse the code figure
out or here's the error message it was
caused by that and then start tracing in
figuring out and often what I find is
that in that case I need to remove that
error message to get at the actual
exception see what actually failed and
then I can dig further and debug the
script
so basically sloppy error handling is
worse than no error handling in Python
because the Python trace backs are
really useful for debugging and just
simplify or remove error handling that
might otherwise obscure the source of
the error and it's basically what I
advocate here and yeah a lot of the
Patton exceptions to escape and
terminate the program
and that will also guarantee a nonzero
exit code from your script so it behaves
like the UNIX convention expects yeah if
there are simple usage or user errors in
your script say like your pasta wrong
number of command-line arguments and
stuff like that that is better handled
with a simple error message because
trying to decode from a traceback that
oh i needed to pass three arguments is
worse than simply the script simply
saying i you need for three arguments
but so i showed your art parse gives you
this for free when you use our parse it
it's going to give you these error
messages also if your script is not
actually run by all the developers if
it's exposed to end users for example
then that's a different story then i
would argue that your script is actually
part of your main code base it's not
glue script and this these rules don't
really apply anymore
so a case study I'm quickly running out
of time so I'm gonna have to run through
this real quickly we build video
conferencing systems we have a build
process that build process creates a pkg
file you then use this script called
bins to take that PKG file and push it
on to video conferencing hardware system
to actually test your functionality so
this is a usual developer workflow this
is the shell script i started with
that's 450 lines of bash
it's not very pleasant it has some
helper functions but the command line
interface alone takes up about half the
script there is there's an almost data
structure in that script that takes
about 30% of the script there is some
logic but it ends up pretty much
constructing this monster command line
in the end so basically we're going to
cut a file which is the PKG file and
we're going to post that over ssh to the
endpoint and we're going to invoke some
stuff on the endpoint to make the
endpoint actually already the video
conferencing system actually install
that PKG as I said it's a complex script
Vince how bins upgrades the conferencing
system is different than how these
conference systems are upgraded in the
field bins pushes the pkg on through
system whereas in the field the system
is told where to find a pkg and then it
pulls it so and also there's a new
requirement on the script we need to
support systems that have multiple
devices and I'm gonna talk about this
here so our conferencing endpoints some
of them are integrated in that you
basically have the whole system in a
single unit with an integrated camera
but you also have bigger systems like
here this is just the camera the main
unit is there or in this case the main
unit is behind the screen but it has two
cameras that are actually separate
separate devices from the main unit and
recall the the main unit we call it the
codec that's more most of the historical
name I guess so you have a codec and you
have a separate camera whereas here you
have the codec in camera in one unit
systems with multiple devices so yeah
basically when you upgrade these
multiple devices systems you need to
upgrade both the codec and the
peripherals in tandem otherwise their
communication link breaks because
they're running different versions so we
introduced some loads files to basically
make sure that when you basically define
which pay KJ's are needed for the codec
and the cameras for those to work
together so that's the simple text
format where it basically tells oh if
you're this kind of codec you need this
pkg if you're like on the camera you
need that pkg and so on and now you're
gonna run one or more build commands and
then run a single bins to update the
codec and its peripherals so instead of
this former workflow we're gonna run
multiple build commands to get multiple
packages for all the all the parts of
the system so basically the codec and
the camera and then we're gonna have a
loads file that references those pkgs
and there's a signature going along with
that loss file and bents is now going to
tell the system about this loads file
and the system will use that loss file
to pull on the pkg it needs so I need to
add stuff to bins to basically deal with
the load files but first and I also need
to serve that loss file to the to the
end point using HTTP that's not going to
be very easy from a shell script so
basically how do we get there I first
needed to rewrite bins from bash into
Python and then
refactor to make it more
readable and then I can start adding new
features so basically first part is or
here are some aspects of the rewrite
from from shell into Python so this is
what I meant with almost data structure
we we have a for loop up here that goes
through the target that you might want
to push and then we can we basically
have a switch case on the different
target names so these are basically
target names from our build system
corresponding to different types of
endpoints and this is basically code
it's not a strut a data structure in
itself it's not reusable as a data
structure it's code that's run directly
inside the shell script but in Python I
can actually create a dictionary and I
can have nice named fields and this when
I import bins from somewhere else I can
actually interrogate this target
structure and get the same information
of the script without running everything
command-line interfaces there are a
couple of helper functions in shell and
then you have this monstrosity which
keeps going for another 100 or so lines
which parses the different command-line
options the corresponding structure in
Python is a fair bit shorter it's a fair
bit more verbose maybe than this but it
has nice documentation for all the
options and everything and it's much
nicer to use from the command line than
the original so the rewrite basically
ended up cutting 19 percent of the lines
from the shell script the command line
interface no no it takes less than 20%
of the file and the data structure takes
about a third old file and at this point
I can start adding new features to the
path script so here basically is a
script for creating those loads files I
talked about and basically the script
itself is children four lines of Python
imported by beams but you can also run
it standalone to create loads files when
you're debugging and ok what if I wanted
to make a Lowe's file that's sort of
formed like this instead then you can
just run the Lowe's file script directly
and it has a nice command-line interface
all documented with the same techniques
that I just showed you we need to sign
those Lowe's files so here's a separate
script load sign that's about three
hundred lines of Python but it base
allows you to sign the Loews files both
for test deployments and for release
deployments here is a Python script that
basically allows you to serve a loads
file and the pkg from a directory to an
endpoint over HTTP and all these are
basically imported from bin stand this
is the code that I had to add to bins to
get that loads behavior added so
basically what we do here is to start a
load server which we go from loads there
and we tell now now we basically log in
to the endpoint and we tell it to find
the loads file to upgrade from and now
the the endpoint will actually pull the
upgrade from our server instead of
pushing it directly onto the endpoint
yeah
and that's pretty much all for the case
study so in summary you can feel free to
use shell scripts for the very simplest
a toss like three lines of shell script
is simpler than seven lines of Python
but as soon as things start growing
really consider rewriting and I would I
would argue we write into Python when
you get more complex logic when you get
data structures everything is going to
be much better in Python write your
Python scripts so they can both be
imported from other scripts to reuse
stuff but also to run them directly from
the command line so you can have nice
developer tools with nice options
refactor mercilessly that goes for any
code base that you care about and unit
tests gives you the confidence to
refactor so that's important when you
start growing and these are the three
modules I would argue most for using
when you build these system utilities
and I'm gonna end on this quote the UNIX
philosophy write programs that do one
thing and do it well write programs to
work together write programs to handle
text frames because that's the universal
interface thanks
no time for questions here but you can
find me no way